hey guys what's up I want to welcome my
channel and today I'm going to be
telling you how to review a video game
so before we actually start reviewing
the thing there are a few different
factors to consider when reviewing a
game most importantly is the style guide
of whichever website you happen to be
reviewing a game forum I'm reviewing you
a game called Chronos and I'm doing it
for each and calm which means I have to
adhere to the IGN style guide and just
for context outside of IGN so you have
some kind of understanding of my
experience I've been professionally
reviewing games for three years now I
would recommend looking at style guides
of some of your favorite reviewers or
some of the websites you'd like to work
for and see how they approach reviewing
games as the first thing but there's
some stuff that you're going to have to
decide by itself probably the most
important thing is a time line for
example I have four days to completely
finish and review Chronos this also
depends on a style guide or an editor
but in general you will need to finish
the game fast I don't take notes while
I'm reviewing a game I know some people
do but I usually just keep it all in my
head one thing I should mention with
that game is that because I knew it had
puzzles I was worried about the time
frame I didn't have that long to play it
in so I played it on easy and then I
started a new game on the hardest
difficulty and one on the medium
difficulty just to see the differences
in combat step two is write the review
since we have a word count this can
actually be very difficult and we start
with the script which is about 400 words
which is not very many so because of
that you have to stick with talking
about what's important about the game
and not everything about the game for
example if there's something that I'm
playing that graphics wise just looks
fine then I'm not going to comment on it
being good or bad because it's not a
major selling point of the game it's not
I made a talking point it's not a major
Pro or condo this is why I think game
reviews are pretty much always
subjective because you are deciding
which of the things presented to you is
important and which isn't and someone
else who's writing the review might
disagree with that opinion so basically
I usually try to write bullet points for
each thing that I think is really
important whether it's a prior record
and then I flush those out into a larger
thing I elaborate on those points I give
examples for the
written version for the video version we
don't need to give examples because you
can show that with gameplay and we'll
get to that in the gameplay recording
part but next to picking what is
particularly important to talk about
it's really important that every single
sentence that you write evaluates the
game in some way a lot of people make
the mistake of writing a sentence that
just says this game does this where you
should be saying this game does this and
this is good or bad because the next
option would be to send it to an editor
if you have one but if you don't to
really thoroughly edit stuff yourself
cut out everything that isn't important
and stick to a word limit if you don't
have someone else giving you one so that
you're not just rambling for a really
really long time so I've sent the script
off to Dan who's the editor and while he
works on the script I will stop writing
the full review because the script is
more important we need to record
gameplay and vo for the video editors
and I won't decide the school that I'm
going to give the game until I have my
full review written so I can kind of
figure out what it riggins like rather
than what I just have in my head that
Noma doesn't just appear out of nowhere
but right now it is 10:00 p.m. so I'm
going to go home and we'll have Dan's
edits tomorrow I'll start on the written
review and I'll start recording gameplay
so at this point you're ready to record
gameplay based off of what is in the
script so I record gameplay after
writing the script not beforehand we
have out gameplay recording setup in
here what I would do is go through my
script and highlight plots of text and
then search for those in the game based
on what I have played some games you
have to start over some games
conveniently have checkpoints so the
script is written with what I know I can
recall it in mind so that when I am
recording the gameplay I know how easy
it'll be to match up to the script but
basically I attach files to the script
so that the editors know exactly what
I'm referring to when they are making
the video so I now have my approved
edits back from Dan basically Dan just
edit spots of the script which we have
here right now this is all been approved
and I have agreed with Dan's edits so we
jump into the vo booth this is a fully
sub / firm which is actually very hot
and I have my script ready to go I will
have someone listening when I'm
recording it to make sure that there
aren't any ones that I stumble on
without realizing make sure the things I
say a consistent because it's really
easy to just say the wrong thing
accidentally and not realize when you're
in front of the camera all recording vo
so let's do it so my review is almost
written have recorded and play a
recorded vo so the video team can start
editing now I have to finish the full
review and work on the score and the
pros and cons which again part of i GN
specific style guide but I will need to
do those to be edited into the video and
wrap the whole thing up so I have
finished writing my full review I think
I've already mentioned most of the
important stuff since we don't use
headers I also make sure to link things
together so I have linking sentences
which you wouldn't normally have in the
video version of the review and we
actually recently got rid of word counts
but I think this one is about 800 words
it was basically just the amount of
words that I needed to touch on all the
most important things without dragging
on for too long and Dan might even cut
out some more of those words to make
sure that I'm not boring people
basically while yes a review is designed
to thoroughly examine something at the
same time it also has to be interesting
to read all people just aren't going to
read it so now that I've written it all
I have to add in a strap line and pros
and cons list which basically IGN
specific thing but I would just base
those on the leading paragraphs in the
review and then I have to decide the
skull okay it's done
I've submitted this to Dan who will give
me my final edits and then the review
will be published this is probably the
last edition I'm gonna make to this
video because when the full thing is up
I'll just I'll just link it so you guys
can actually see my full review and see
how it turned out and you know you'll
see the stuff that I mentioned in this
now I feel like I covered all of the
main talking points for reviewing a game
in this I can't think of there's
anything I've forgotten because I've
been you know doing this video over a
series of days and not all at once so I
kind of forgetting what I've already
spoken about at this point and yeah I
guess finally I assume that most people
who are watching this video will be
people who don't already review games
and would like to start doing it
professionally and the best way to do
that is to just start doing it start
writing all the time and then when
you're more confident with your writing
start reaching out to people at events
handing a business card or emailing
examples of your work talking people on
Twitter it's a lot of networking
involved so that people can see your
work
and start with smaller sides hopefully
got feedback and then build your way up
from that so you're definitely not going
to be starting with IGN for most people
you wouldn't I assume I wrote unpaid for
I think six months to a year when I
first started out and that's kind of
just the reality of this kind of field
but lastly if you have any questions let
me know and if anyone writes a review
that they publish online link it to me
on my Facebook page probably and I would
be more than happy to find some time to
read it and give you some feedback
because honestly getting feedback from
people even if it's just like someone
you know who's a good writer
is the best way to grow and everyone
needs feedback I still need feedback and
of course last but not least is try not
to read the comments because no matter
what people will disagree with you it
doesn't matter the review is an opinion
keep writing don't let it just hot in
here and if you're passionate about it
you're a passionate writer then maybe
you'll be able to end up doing it
full-time one day wouldn't that be cool
I wanna I hope you guys enjoyed this
video I will see you all next time